حسنًا ، لقد مر وقت طويل منذ أن حصلت
وكالة ناسا على أحد صواريخها الخاصة
المصممة لنقل رواد الفضاء إلى الفضاء
، لقد مرت 11 عامًا منذ آخر
إطلاق لمكوك فضائي منذ 50 عامًا على
الإطلاق الأخير لبرنامج أبولو ، ولكن الآن
شقيقة أبولو الأسطورية التوأم
أرتميس  تجلس على منصة الإطلاق في
مركز كينيدي للفضاء على بعد أيام فقط
من القيام بأول رحلة لها وجزء
من سبب رغبة ناسا في العودة إلى
القمر لأن هذه المرة
يريدون ترك أكثر بكثير من مجرد أعلام
وآثار أقدام هنا  مدير ناسا
بيل نيلسون قبل 50 عامًا ذهبنا إلى
القمر ليوم واحد في غضون ساعات قليلة وثلاثة أيام
كحد أقصى ،
والآن نعود إلى القمر
للعيش لتعلم
البناء وعندما يقول البناء فإنه يشير
إلى بناء القمر  قواعد على سطح القمر
وجزء من سبب رغبة ناسا والولايات
المتحدة في القيام بذلك هو أن الصين
لديها خطط للقيام بذلك أيضًا ، ولكن أولاً ، يجب على
صاروخ Artemis اجتياز هذه
الرحلة التجريبية الحاسمة ، حيث سيطلق Monda
صباحًا ، إذا سارت الأمور وفقًا
للخطة ، فسوف ينفصل الصاروخ
عن الكبسولة وسوف تتجه الكبسولة
إلى القمر من تلقاء نفسها ، وستدور
حول القمر لمدة أسبوعين ونصف تقريبًا في
بعض الأحيان على بعد 60 ميلاً فقط من
القمر.  السطح ثم يعود إلى
الأرض ويختبر هذا الدرع الحراري المهم للغاية
قبل أن يتناثر في
المحيط الهادئ والسبب في أن
الدرع الحراري مهم جدًا لأنه
مصمم لحماية رواد الفضاء الذين
سيكونون داخل تلك الكبسولة على أمل
الرحلات المستقبلية و  لذلك إذا سارت الأمور على ما يرام ،
فسيكون رواد الفضاء الأوائل في
Artemis 2 والذي من المحتمل أن يكون في عام 2024 وسيدور
حول القمر ثم المدار
الكبير Artemis الثلاثة عندما
تنوي ناسا إعادة رواد الفضاء الأمريكيين
إلى القمر